you disrespectful don't care
rather hang out with your friends all
night here you guys want to know a fact
how many nights has she stayed with me
says christmas
once now i don't know where christmas
falls on this timeline
but one night doesn't sound like enough
that is not
how a wife acts in any country i don't
care what language you speak or
anything else anyone in the room
disagree
nope i agree mike had what some might
call a meltdown
get with the program or get out but i
call it an explosion
he went off on natalie you want to get
into this it's going to be bad natalie
first christmas how many gifts did i get
you natalie
and what did you do with all my gifts go
ahead
y'all just wait until you hear what she
did
it was actually worse than i thought
that is childish
it's like a seven-year-old throwing a
tantrum
we'll get into what led up to this
latest argument that i'm sure has us all
saying
enough already how much proof do you
need to know
that someone is not the one i mean the
intimacy can't be that good
there's no way plus andre got cake
thrown in his face by libby's sister jen
during a nasty fight concerning the
family business
now the question is did he deserve it or
are libby's sisters getting out of
control jen and rebecca are acting like
teenagers
i'm done with it i don't want to take it
anymore we're going to talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
mike and natalie's relationship
continues to dwindle
and natalie's new friend juliana has me
a little suspicious
[Music]
before we get into that let's talk about
mike exploding on natalie after she
brought up his mom
allegedly calling her a hooker during
thanksgiving she said
cuckoo for the hundredth time
so it is it is in my head
awkward i have eyes i have i have ears
and i have brain
god gave me this you also have voice too
so you could talk
mike was so frustrated that he decided
to get up which caused natalie to give
this little spill right here
she has no reason to call me that way no
reason correct
she has nobody's going to call you that
i ask why enough
okay well to end that mike went to get
his phone so natalie could finally ask
his mom
for the first time if she called her
hooker now
before we get into his mother's very
strong choice of words for natalie
i will say that a part of me understands
where natalie is coming from
okay i'm crazy okay
because i too have had moments yeah
where i thought i heard someone say
something
and although the person swore they
didn't say it
i knew i wasn't crazy and it's everybody
play like it never happened
but then i had to check myself and ask
what part of me is looking or waiting
for this person to say something
disrespectful because if you're looking
for proof that someone doesn't like you
more than likely your mind will conjure
up all types of ways to find it
that's why you can't believe every
thought you have or you'll be sitting
over here like natalie
stressing over something that didn't
even happen i haven't talked to you
since
we left elsa right what is your
impression about me and what did they do
to make you feel
that way you do not treat michael kindly
michael provides you with everything
everything and you be mean to him
all the time trish what he buys food for
me to survive until i get work permit
a roof over your head a car for you to
drive shoot he married you
if it wasn't for him you will be back
with your mama in ukraine
ask her the question that she called her
for you think my mom calls you a hooker
so ask her i don't ask her she tells me
i'm using you
now listen to me i never ever
came close to calling you a hooker or
anything else do you understand me i
never
did that i don't know where you come up
with that
but you need to knock it off you need to
understand that
why i get mad at you is you don't be
nice to my son
you can't tell me that you love him i
don't believe for a second
that you love him none of us do trish
none of us do it's like natalie didn't
want to find out she was wrong
and all of this got me thinking natalie
probably thinks trish called her a
hooker
because that's how she talks to people
you remember
during the tell-off for season 8 of 90
day fiance
mike's best friend opened up about a
comment that natalie randomly said to
her when they first
met over face time she asked me if
all american women were [ __ ] or if it
was just me
and that was right after the hello hi
nice to meet you
yes anyway back to mike's explosion
you want to get into this it's going to
be bad natalie
first christmas how many gifts did i get
you natalie
and what did you do with all my gifts go
ahead
tell what did you do with all the lovely
gifts i got you
please you took all the gifts that i
gave you for christmas
you went to your best friend's house and
gave it to her and her whole family for
christmas gifts
this is true yes i'm down for re-gifting
but that is
not the way to go about it i thought he
was going to say that she burned the
gifts out of anger
which i don't know why but it sounds
better to me than giving them away to
her friend's family
i guess burning them involves more
passion and giving them away is clearly
saying i don't give a [ __ ] about you or
anything that you do don't give a [ __ ]
about you or anything that you do
that was the perfect song oh and then
natalie hung up on mike's mom
what are you telling your friends when
you're giving all of this stuff to them
let me speak i really wanted her to
answer that question
natalie's relationship with her new best
friend juliana seems to be causing
more issues in her and mike's marriage
issues
on top of the issues they already had
listen to this interesting bit of tea
that mike spilled
after he revealed that natalie has only
stayed with him one night since
christmas
all the other nights she's been at
juliana aka julia's house
tell me natalie why why
according to natalie it's because she
and mike fight a lot
because you fight and you ignore it no
we don't fight all the time darling
we're not fighting
we haven't fought last night we didn't
fight the night before we didn't fight
the night before
we made love the night before you got up
and
10 minutes later you were out the door
to julia's house
i have my rooms there oh you have a room
wow she's got a room now
she's an official mover in her now she's
got a room
wow how far am i on the back end
like i mean there are so many people
ahead of me that are way more important
than me
your husband what the is wrong with you
well you made the choice to marry her
mike
natalie says she's been gone because
trish called her a bad name
which just sounded like a lame excuse
and mike felt that
there's just no love at all for me
nothing there's nothing i'm out
i am so over this thank you have a great
night everyone
michael when i'm wrong i'd meet when i'm
not i don't what can i say
literally there's no do you love me or
anything
i do love you but you shot me a lot i do
love you but what's the way you treat me
how do i have to feel i don't know
because you're not home and i don't know
because you don't talk to me
just watching this got my blood boiling
because although we don't know
everything that goes on in that
relationship
i really can't recall mike treating her
badly while on the show
besides calling off the wedding last
minute and a part of that was
understandable
if anything this man has been too nice
and beyond patient
i don't know what natalie wants from
mike i think it's one of those
situations where they both don't want to
be in the relationship
but neither of them want to be the first
to walk away and this julia woman she
seems cool and all but
i'm not gonna lie the preview for next
week has me a little
curious about her and natalie's
relationship where's ellie right now
she's that giuliana's she's a snake in
the grass
she doesn't even like you i'm not sure
where to go with ali right now
i am going to try to keep working on it
the question is is
she going to work on it with me
yes
yeah it was just something about that
final grin that got me
i don't know all right well quickly
let's get into andre getting cake
smashed in his face by libby's sister
why are you being such a as we know
andre and elizabeth siblings have been
going at it
all season because their dad chuck has
allowed andre to get into the family
real estate business
and they're basically scared that andre
is going to take their jobs
seems like dad's just kind of like
handing him stuff no he wasn't
tensions were expected to go up a notch
this episode
after chuck gave andre his own house to
flip and told him that he could also be
the listening agent
we are looking to rent one of the moon
bounces for her birthday
so ahead of her daughter's second
birthday celebration libby updated her
sisters on andre's latest opportunity
so they wouldn't find out at the party
and ruin it i even encouraged him to get
his license i helped him
study for the test but then he doesn't
even
care that he would be stepping on my
toes he's putting in an effort and he's
working hard also
you have to give him credit for that
he's actually taking money out of our
pocket for our family yeah so i would be
taking money out of your pocket because
i started putting in an effort and he's
renovating it and he's flipping it
it's not like it was yours or you had
dibs on it it doesn't matter
but dad's investing in a property for
him
which he could have been investing with
in a property with us or me
i get their concern but it also sounds a
little selfish
fast forward to the actual birthday
party everyone promised that they would
be good
i mean we're gonna try to set our
differences aside today but it's an
elephant in the room
yeah it's an elephant in the room but
things took a dramatic turn
when andre tried to cut the cake before
they sung happy birthday to the baby
you're not supposed to cut it yet you
have to sing happy birthday to your
daughter
what are you doing what are you
controlling this no andre
that's common sense yeah it is even
after they sang happy birthday the damn
cake continued to be an issue
until it ended up on andre's face
they're babies they're not good
what are you doing
we all know that this is more than just
about the cake which
looks delicious by the way i can see why
andre wanted to cut it so quickly
but here's when their real feelings came
out i don't like when people mess with
my money
messing with my finger at us like you're
better than us i want to hear what they
have to say i already told you
i think my girls are definitely
overracking this deal because this
is just one of the houses that we're
flipping and they think
it's going to be the whole entire
company that's not the case
no you'll look at me in that way
house yes he just said leave my birthday
house
she is obviously feeling the bubbly look
this is my thing if you think someone is
going to come in and take your job
you don't spend your time trying to kick
them out you spend your time
working hard to prove that you're
irreplaceable
i think my girls are definitely
overracking this deal
to me at this point becky and jen are
just misplacing their energy
and although andre can be a little foul
at the mouth he is not really the main
problem anymore
they are jen straight away through the
cake into my face
and it's disgusting move and this is the
last straw
jen and rebecca are acting like
teenagers i'm done with it i don't want
to take it anymore
all right well next week here comes
chuck trying to plan yet
another family gathering in an attempt
to make peace
even though his attempts have ended in
disaster the last few times
i have to have my family back together
like it was before
so i'm gonna have a family cookout and i
want everybody to be there
honestly i think this cookout is gonna
be so
bad when we go to this barbecue i feel
like i'm definitely gonna confront dad
about andre
you will 100 why not you're a
businessman chuck
if this family gathering approach hasn't
worked yet
let's try something else right now it's
gonna get fiery
also when i spoke with andre not too
long ago he told me that he was going to
expose libby's siblings it's going to
come some surprises over here
and some investigation that i did and
what i knew
what i discovered while working with
chuck what matters the rest of the
family so it's going to become
interesting because
it's not what really everybody was
thinking about me it's actually what
it's actually the reality about the
other siblings in my family like but
forever siblings are going to get a
little bit exposed
i'm not sure exactly what he meant by
that but i guess we'll see soon
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
you